pep bestelle ich ein hemd für meinen
bewerbungsgespräch auf instagram bekomme
ich werbung für neue sportschuhe und
eine winterjacke gibt es bestimmt
irgendwo im sale
wir kaufen bereits unglaublich viel aber
hersteller produzieren noch mehr wie
befriedigen diese hersteller den
ständigen hunger nach neuem das
stichwort hier ist fast fashion
kurzlebige billige klamotten für die
breite masse aber ist fast fashion nicht
total out sie ist umweltschädlich
produziert viel zu viel und was sich
nicht verkauft wird einfach verbrannt
alles gute punkte aber leider nein fast
fashion wird zwar gerade abgelöst aber
der nachfolger ist noch katastrophaler
noch schneller und vor allem ein noch
größeres problem für unsere umwelt
[Musik]
das hat nichts mehr mit qualität zu tun
man weiß es aber
manche trotzdem immer noch weiter
einkaufen
die modeindustrie sucht händeringend
nach einem neuen image am liebsten
nachhaltig recycelt und natürlich so
nähern sie sich immer mehr dem gegenteil
von fast fashion der sogenannten slow
fashion oft passiert so etwas weniger
aus überzeugung sondern weil man so eine
junge engagierte zielgruppe ansprechen
möchte aber egal ob ehrlich oder aus
profitgründen das hört sich ja erst mal
ganz gut an
nur während große sportmarken vielleicht
ein paar nachhaltige produkte auf den
markt bringen
verläuft der rest eigentlich so wie
gehabt und trotzdem werden sie überholt
neue marktführer produzieren wie das low
noch fast fashion sondern ultra fast
fashion
das heißt anstatt alle vier wochen neue
sachen im laden zu sehen werden 4500
teile pro woche online auf den markt
geworfen
der design zyklus dauert teilweise nur
zwei wochen von der idee bis zum
fertigen produkt bei dir zu hause
zum vergleich bei fast fashion riesen
dauert das in der regel immerhin fünf
wochen zu schaffen es ultra fast fashion
unternehmen 52 kollektionen im jahr zu
produzieren
jede woche gibt es etwas neues sollte
hersteller sind größtenteils nur online
und bewerben produkte auf instagram
bevor sie überhaupt produziert wurden
ultra fast fashion treibt die masse und
frequenz von fast fashion auf die spitze
und stellt dadurch ein noch größeres
problem für die umwelt dar denn wird ein
hersteller die t shirts nicht mal im 90%
sale los dann werden die anziehsachen
einfach verbrannt sie zu lagern oder zu
spenden wäre für die unternehmen noch
teurer
eines der größten probleme sind die
materialien viele textilien ungefähr 60
sind chemischen ursprungs tatsächlich
kann man ein prozent des weltweiten
ölverbrauchs auf die textilherstellung
zurückführen
und das ohne die rohstoffe die in
verpackung und den transport fließen
da gibt es zum beispiel polyester dass
80 prozent der chemischen textilien
ausmacht das kennt man zum beispiel von
sportklamotten man findet es aber auch
in bettbezügen und sogar ganz normalen t
shirts polyester ist erdöl basiert und
in der herstellung super energieintensiv
aber warum produzieren so viele
hersteller ihre klamotten mit polyester
für sportbekleidung ist polyester schön
luftig und sogar wasserabweisend
das ist praktisch aber der eigentliche
grund warum so viel mit polyester
produziert wird ist der preis mit
polyester können unternehmen der enormen
nachfrage an kleidung gerecht werden
bei regulärer kleidung machen macht
projekt da einfach wirklich keinen sinn
weil es hat keinen trage konformen
stinkt man muss es öfter waschen weil es
schneller geht das ist halt einfach
nicht ressourcenschonend aber eben
supergünstig im gegensatz natürlich zu
organischen stoffen weil die müssen
natürlich angebaut werden und es ist
halt aufwendiger in der verarbeitung und
wenn wir schon mal dabei sind durch den
abrieb beim waschen von polyester und
anderen chemischer gestellten textilien
landet micro plastik im grundwasser und
damit auf lange sicht auch bei uns im
körper erklärt übrigens in diesem video
hier gerne mal drauf klicken falls euch
das interessiert billige verarbeitung
mit günstigen textilien sorgt auch dafür
dass kleidung viel kürzer hält für
hersteller ist das ein winwin szenario
kunden können viel kaufen weil es
günstig ist wollen aber auch schnell
viele neue sachen weil sie einfach nicht
lange halten um möglichst viele und
möglichst günstige produkte in eine
filiale in deiner nähe zu bringen müssen
hersteller an allen ecken und enden
sparen materialien verarbeitung aber vor
allem auch personal und transport und
damit man also weiter t shirts für fünf
euro kaufen kann muss die arbeit nach
asien afrika oder lateinamerika
ausgelagert werden
hinzu kommt dass die textilproduktion
schon lange aus vielen europäischen
ländern verschwunden ist
aufgrund der globalisierung fehlt es
hier vor allem an fachkräften und
letztendlich unternehmen und baumwolle
lässt sich in den meisten europäischen
ländern sowieso gar nicht anbauen
in asien oder afrika können hersteller
unter weniger strengen auflagen
produzieren und müssen ihre angestellten
auch viel weniger bezahlen als
beispielsweise in deutschland geld wird
hier auch bei den produktionsbedingungen
spart die umweltauflagen für die
produktion sind viel lockerer als in
vielen europäischen ländern
ok fassen wir einmal zusammen egal ob
sie über die materialien die produktion
oder den transport sprechen ein roter
faden lässt sich bei fast und ultra fast
fashion auf jeden fall erkennen um so
viele klamotten in so einer
geschwindigkeit bereit zu stellen und
gleichzeitig profitabel zu sein muss an
allen ecken gespart werden
gehälter verarbeitung materialien fast
und ultra fast fashion sind also ein
echtes problem aber kein nötiges übel
[Musik]
slow fashion ist so etwas wie der
gegenentwurf zu fast und ultra fast
fashion designerinnen und designer
setzen hier auf innovative materialien
lokale arbeitsbedingungen und
nachhaltige produktion
wichtig ist hier vor allem die
geschwindigkeit durch die weniger
geschwindigkeit und weniger masse bei
der produktion haben solche hersteller
die möglichkeit auf nachhaltigkeit und
qualität wert zulegen und wer könnte uns
das besser erklären als ein slow fashion
label ja ich bin ganz
wir sind hier bei ship shape wir
produzieren fair und ökologisch
produzierte mode seit 2008 10
wir wollten wirklich mal selber ein
faires produkt produzieren das war noch
vor 2018 bevor wir wirklich offiziell
angefangen haben kollektionen zweimal im
jahr zu produzieren und eben auch auf
den messen ja wirklich in die wirtschaft
einzutauchen
slow fashion fängt schon bei den
materialien an und die wohl
vielversprechendste alternative zu
polyester wird schon mega häufig
verwendete baumwolle die kommen nämlich
ohne erdöl aus und macht schon die
hälfte aller textilien weltweit aus dazu
kommt dass kleidung aus baumwolle
einfach hochwertiger ist als misch
textilien mit polyester wenn slow
fashion aus baumwolle dann auch noch
besser verarbeitet wird dann verlässt
ein t shirt oder dein hemd nicht nach
einem jahr den kreislauf du kannst
kleidung also ganz einfach weiter
verkaufen oder spenden weil die qualität
nicht nach zwanzig waschgängen den bach
runter gegangen ist wenn also die
baumwollindustrie wächst verliert dann
die textilindustrie ihr dreckiges image
leider nein baumwolle verzichtet zwar
auf erdöl gut aber für die produktion
werden große mengen wasser gebraucht
schlecht für eine einzige jeans braucht
man zum beispiel ungefähr 8000 liter
wasser
man denkt immer also haben wir alles das
beste was ich machen kann aber bauen
weil es gar nicht unbedingt das was an
ressourcenschonenden ist aber da gibt es
auch schon alternativen wie zum beispiel
tänze das ist jetzt eigentlich nur
organische also eine faser die chemische
hergestellt wird aber aus organischen
stoffen also aus zellulose und das sind
geschlossener kreislauf und das ist auch
was wo ich sagen würde
da müssen wir hinkommen weil das
nachwachsender rohstoff und das wasser
wird halt wieder auf breite da geht halt
einfach nichts mehr verloren und es hat
trotzdem noch die trageeigenschaften die
wir uns wünschen es trocknet schnell das
ist angenehmer auf der haut auch
allergiker vertragen dass damit auch der
transport von klamotten einem
niedrigeren co2 ausstoß verursacht
versuchen viele slow fashion brands die
produktion zu zentralisieren
anstatt also die baumwolle aus indien
nach taiwan zum färben dann nach
bangladesch zu nehmen und letztendlich
nach portugal zum verpacken zu schicken
wird so viel wie möglich an einem ort
gemacht
idealerweise so nah wie möglich am
verkaufsort die materialien und der
transporte sind aber nicht das einzige
problem der branche vor allem ultra fast
fashion produziert einfach zu viel
slow fashion kann auch bedeuten den
rhythmus zu ändern anstatt große
kollektion zu produzieren die für eine
überlastung der produktionskette sorgen
steigen hersteller auf sogenannte jobs
um das bedeutet kleidung wird das ganze
jahr über stückchenweise veröffentlicht
und ok das klingt jetzt erstmal sowie
ultra fast fashion aber der große
unterschied ist hier dass sie nicht jede
woche ganze kollektion veröffentlicht
werden sondern vielleicht nur ein bis
zwei kleidungsstücke
so muss zum beispiel die
baumwollproduktion in indien nicht für
eine sommerkollektion komplett
hochfahren um danach dann wieder leute
kündigen zu müssen sondern sie kann das
ganze jahr über unter moderater
belastung arbeiten
trotzdem ist man zumindest teilweise
noch an die marotten der modeindustrie
gebunden
die fashion week sind zum beispiel
lebensnotwendig vor allem für kleine
unternehmen und dort orientiert man sich
zeitlich nun mal an den etablierten
kollektions modellen
viele dieser probleme werden durch
kleinere slow fashion brands wie ship
shape schon gelöst und wie eben schon
erwähnt springe auch immer mehr große
hersteller auf den trend auf tour und
schuhe aus meeres plastik oder
nachhaltige shirts allerdings solltet
ihr bei diesen begriffen erst mal
stutzig werden denn weder nachhaltig
noch meeres plastik sind geschützte
begriffe
sie können also theoretisch frei
verwendet werden ohne dass ein
hersteller auch wirklich nachhaltig
produzieren muss hinzu kommt dass noch
keine namenhafte fast oder ultra fast
fashion marke einen kompletten umstieg
hin zu nachhaltiger oder biobasierter
mode angekündigt hat viele große
hersteller betreiben sogenanntes
greenwashing sie geben nach außen hin
ein nachhaltiges image vor
während 99 prozent der produktion
eigentlich genau so verläuft wie gehabt
das wirft fragen
geht zum beispiel fast fashion überhaupt
nachhaltig ist es möglich für konzerne
wie h&m oder source die gleiche leistung
nachhaltig zu liefern und um das direkt
mal aus dem weg zu räumen
fast fashion kann nicht umweltfreundlich
sein das ist ein widerspruch in sich
ja manche fast fashion riesen bieten
jetzt recycling an
aber es ist unmöglich auf diese art und
weise 52 kollektion im jahr auf die
beine zu stellen
denn aktuell werden nur ein prozent
aller textilien weltweit überhaupt
recycelt fast fashion und ultra fast
fashion sind antithese zur
nachhaltigkeit
es liegt vor allem an dem ehrgeizigen
ziel solcher konzerne jedes jahr wachsen
zu müssen
mehr stores mehr kollektion mehr auswahl
und dadurch natürlich mehr geld
hersteller haben sich so einen
konsumenten herangezogen der genau das
möchte jede woche neue produkte und am
besten günstig und irgendwie kann man es
auch nachvollziehen dass man nicht für
40 oder 50 euro t shirt kaufen will
sondern vielleicht für zehn oder sogar
nur für 5 euro geld sparen ist mal
genauso einen grundstein des
kapitalismus wie geld ausgeben
das heißt wenn wir nicht die frequenz
und masse des konsums ändern wird sich
der ökologische fußabdruck auch nicht
reduzieren lassen
um nachhaltige kleidung zu produzieren
müssen hersteller weg von kurzlebiger
massenproduktion und hin zu kleidung die
nachhaltig produziert wird und vor allem
lange hält und so den wirtschaftlichen
kreislauf nicht verlässt
denn mode für alle geht auch ohne die
umweltfolgen der textilindustrie nur
nicht in diesem ausmaß aber muss es das
überhaupt sein brauche ich 50 oder 60
teile in meinem kleiderschrank reichen
nicht 20 ich glaube zum einen ist es
nicht möglich die nachfrage die im
moment ist zu bedienen aber das muss
eben auch nicht wenn man darauf achtet
dass man
produkte wieder qualitativer gestaltet
und dafür müssen wir auf jeden fall
unseren konsum reduzieren also das lässt
sich so nicht fortführen es muss auf
jeden fall runtergefahren werden also
die geschwindigkeit muss runter gefahren
werden und dafür müssen produkte wieder
langlebiger und hochwertiger reduziert
werden
sosehr fast fashion auch gefragt ist das
bewusstsein für die folgen der
textilindustrie wächst und das ist gut
so
im internationalen vergleich liegen
deutsche im internet am häufigsten nach
fair fashion und neben ship shape gibt
es eine ganze reihe an nachhaltigen slow
fashion labels die in fast jeder
deutschen großstadt
wenn euch das interessiert dann für die
dem bestimmt welche im internet
das hat natürlich seinen preis slow
fashion shopping heißt dass wir den
laden nicht mit drei vollen tüten
verlassen werden es sei denn sie
investieren eine große stange geld
einerseits liegt das daran dass qualität
natürlich ihren preis hat
andererseits sind viele slow fashion
labels noch klein und produzierenden
niedriger auflage das den preis genauso
nach oben treibt wenn man aber bereit
ist etwas mehr geld zu investieren dann
kann jeder von uns einen unterschied
machen
der beste erste schritt ist sich bewusst
zu werden welche folgen der eigene
konsum hat das hier war die dritte folge
unserer serie für das wissenschaftsjahr
2020 bioökonomie danke an das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung und die gemeinnützige
organisation wissenschaft im dialog für
die unterstützung bei diesem video
im ersten teil der serie geht es um die
lösung des problems von dem ich gerade
gesprochen habe stetiges wachstum kann
nicht funktionieren wir brauchen also
ein besseres system und wie das aussehen
kann
das beschreibe ich in diesem video und
im zweiten teil der serie geht es um die
stadt der zukunft und warum sie
vielleicht ganz anders aussieht als wir
das vielleicht aus film und fernsehen
kennen schaut euch die videos auf jeden
fall an
falls euch das interessiert und mich
interessiert jetzt natürlich eure
meinung lassen uns gerne in den
kommentaren diskutieren können wir
komplett auf slow fashion umsteigen
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt neugierig